En enormt viktig del av varumärke är ju volym av människor som bryr sig.
Om ingen bryr sig och du har jättesnygg font, det är helt useless.
Men om du har lite mindre snägg font och jättemånga bryr sig, då har du i alla fall ett varumärke att prata om.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu byter vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har reda i en bra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Det är dags igen.
Då sitter jag här med Jacob Wibom Westberg på OJ.
Mannen som har kanske Stockholms vackraste frisyr.
Känner du, när du tittar på mig, hur kan man ha begått ett sånt förfall på sig själv som människa?
Jag hade exakt samma frisyr.
Ja, räckte gott.
Bra, då har vi hamnat där.
Jag tänkte att vi börjar någonstans i varumärkesdiskussionen kring att bygga varumärket som e-handlare.
Jag har ju lite svårt, dels var jag väldigt svår för när du och Björn säger brand, jag tycker att det är ett varumärke.
Finns det någon egentligen skillnad där?
Och nummer två, vad innebär det att bygga varumärke?
Det blir väldigt flummigt liksom.
När jag och Björn säger brand, är det Paul-Manspengers som du drar in?
Nej, men han säger alltid brand.
Ja, nej men, jag vet inte, det är väl bara en flosk.
Man säger brandbildning, man slänger köverlag med en hel del engelska termer.
Jag är väl en av dem som gör det värst kanske.
Men nej, men det är väl inget skillnad i det.
Varumärke och brand är väl exakt samma sak.
Men, jag vet inte exakt var vi ska börja någonstans.
Om jag är en e-handlare, i början så börjar jag egentligen bara tänka att jag ska få upp en e-handel, nu ska jag börja sälja den, produkten.
Och sen någonstans i marknadsföringens gång så slutar marknadsföringen vara linjär och det börjar bli trögt i marknadsföringen.
Du kan inte längre lägga in 50% mer och få 50% mer output.
Där någonstans brukar man ju komma till smarta människor och så säger man, hej vad ska jag göra med mitt liv nu?
Och då säger de, ja du måste börja bygga varumärke så att du når ut till folk.
För att ett varumärke ska vara värdefullt så måste du i slutändan ha en finansiell impact på din resa.
Du tar exemplet när det handlar om kundanskaffningen ungefär, låter du som.
Om tillväxten slutar hända så gör det antagligen att man inte lyckas ta in nya kunder på samma sätt längre.
För att ett varumärke ska vara värdefullt så måste du antingen lyckas ta ut det i termer av ett prispremium.
Om du är Nike så kanske du har pricing power på samma produkt eller en produkt som är lika bra gentemot ett nytt skovarumärke som du inte har samma tilltro till.
Det är väl ett sätt att ta ut varumärken, men det andra är ju att du är på något sätt alltid i consideration-set för människor när de ska köpa en viss kategori.
Så tänker du att Nike är ett av de varumärken jag tänker på när jag ska köpa skor.
Det gör ju att det direkt blir billigare att hitta nya kunder.
Och sen så finns det möjligen andra aspekter.
Apple är ju ett varumärke som många har en relation till.
Jag gillar, eller har i alla fall genom åren gillat Apple, även om min kärlek för varumärket kanske var lite lägre nu än vad de var förr.
Men om de hade släppt en TV för tio år sedan då kan man garantera att jag hade köpt en point blank bara för att Apple släppte en TV.
Då har man ju ändå på något sätt lyckats bygga upp ett starkt varumärke.
Jag tror att visstligen det varumärket är väldigt mycket byggt på deras produkter.
Snarare än att jag liksom, jag vet inte ens vad Apples värdeord är eller liksom jag vet inte om de har något större why men jag har alltid gillat hur de designar produkter.
Jag har tyckt att det var ändå engagerande nog att sitta när de släpper nya produkter varje år under en period av mitt liv, inte längre, och därför hade jag nog varit beredd att köpa den där TV-an.
Så då har man ju ändå genom en produktupplevelse och en användarupplevelse av de produkterna skapat ett varumärke starkt nog för att få mig att vilja luta mig in i och köpa deras nästa produkt.
Så det här är väl olika exempel på hur man kan använda varumärket och Apple är ju också väldigt bra på att ta hög prispunkt för sina produkter.
Men rent kasta, om man är ett random bolag som omsätter 20 miljoner i alla, ska man bygga varumärket då?
Men jag tror att det är viktigt för dig, det är viktigt att definiera hur du vill porträttera dig ut mot marknaden för att se om, och det beror också lite på det i förproduktkategori, om du är i en bransch där det är viktigt att du är aspirationell, vilket jag tror att i fashion till exempel, så är det väldigt viktigt att i alla fall på premiumsidan av fashion, så för att du ska vara villig att betala mer för ett par jeans, som du teoretiskt sett skulle kunna köpa från ganska många olika platser, då måste du känna att när du köper dem från ett visst varumärke, så gör det att människor ser på dig som någon annan.
Du kanske inte uttrycker det så, men det är ändå någonstans i slutändan det det handlar om, att andra människor ser när du har på de här jeansen, och du känner att det här är en del av mig.
Då lyckades ju du bygga någon form av aspirationell värld som människor vill utas in i.
Är du ett problem to solution, var du märker, eller du har en produkt som är mer så här, du löser någon form av problem, då är inte ribban, det är inte samma höga ribba för att människor ska vilja vara en del av din värld, utan då handlar det mer om att nå en acceptabel nivå, av att man känner att de här gör ändå bra grejer för sustainability kanske, eller vad man nu har för bedömningskriterier.
Men det är inte riktigt lika viktigt att man måste vilja vara en del av den här världen lika mycket, utan då kanske det är viktigt att din produkt bara är bättre, eventuellt bättre prisad än en konkurrent.
Jag tycker att det blir så jävla flummigt, så jävla fort.
Du går ju i sig runt i ganska mycket gymkompaniets kläder, men många människor gillar ju att säga att jag köper Ralph Lauren-kläder till våra barn.
Det är ju i stor utsträckning för Ralph Lauren att lyckas bygga en värld där, eller liksom en varumärkesvärld, där man tycker att det ser väldigt härligt ut, där föräldrarna och barnen springer runt på en gräsmatta.
Vi har inte ens en gräsmatta liksom, men jag vill ändå vara en del av den här världen och känna att där är mina barn och ju allting är härligt när de springer runt i stället för att färglada.
Fan, vi är två olika människor.
Jag har tänkt att jag har en gräsmatta men de har inga ralflorenkläder.
Jag har valt andra approachen på det varumärket.
De kör gymkompaniot i stället.
De har gymkompaniot.
Det är klart de har.
Allting som går att dra på företaget, vi ska dra oss av på företaget.
Det är merch.
Det är reklam.
Jag kan tycka att det blir väldigt flummigt när vi var lite mindre än nu.
Jag börjar tycka att vi kan börja bygga varumärken nu.
Nu börjar jag tänka på någon sorts upper funnel om det vi ska prata om.
Nu börjar jag tänka såhär, okej vi behöver nå ut till folk.
Tidigare har jag tyckt att hela min varumärkesdiskussion har egentligen bara handlat om att äga produkter eller kategorier.
För mig har varumärkesarbete fram tills nu egentligen bara handlat om att om jag vill bli stor på Kettebells, hur ser jag till att bli bäst i det sortimentet?
Vad är det folk bryr sig om på Kettebells?
Ska jag vara lågt prisbra eller ska jag köpa direkt från fabrik?
Vi ska ha det här, det är väldigt rudimentärt och liknande.
Det är inte så fokuserat på att varumärket i sig ska ha en känsla eller att du ska vara med i vårt community, utan det är mycket mer baserat på transaktionell värde.
Har ni aldrig sponsrat någonting med Kettebells?
Jo, absolut.
Under många år sponsrar vi hela Strångvän-världen i Sverige.
Det är ju om något varumärkesbyggande mot en grupp.
Du försöker inte sälja en produkt när du sätter redan en logotype på någons tröja i den världen, utan du försöker skapa en preferens för att man ska komma till en butik och köpa egentligen vad som helst.
Men det är ju mycket mer baserat på att jag bara tyckte det var kul, det är ingenting vi haft något mätvärde på.
Mäter du någonsin varumärke?
Det kan man ju göra på många olika sätt såklart.
Om man är i en enkelt sätt att se eller ett enkelt sätt att se hur pass väl ett varumärke fungerar ju bara att se hur mycket människor som söker på varumärket.
Och vi eller produkter som är helt unika för det varumärket som du på något sätt kan definiera i ord kan ju vara ett annat sätt också.
Men det är ganska svårt att mäta effekten av varumärkes insatser över tid.
Alltså det finns absolut tappra försök till det med M&M modellering och andra grejer.
Men det är i slutändan relativt svårt.
Och jag skulle liksom säga att framförallt som litet DTC-bolag så är det otroligt svårt att se en varumärkesplacering som faktiskt makes sense om du inte kan hitta de här typ nischade placeringarna som ni gör då i strongman-tävlingar till exempel, då vet du att typ alla som är där ska någon gång köpa en kettlebell och hänns ser det här en ganska bra grupp att vända sig till.
Men om man tänker på traditionella så här out of home eller TV eller den typen av grejer där man liksom blastar ut mot en enormt stor del av populationen, så är det ju svårt att tro att det är en logisk placering för ett varumärk som har omsett till 20 miljoner kronor för att uppenbarligen vad du ens säljer så är det nästan ingen som handlar i den butiken.
Då är det ingen bra idé att försöka vända sig till hela Sveriges befolkning och berätta om din butik, probably, för att du behöver skapa en butik som är relevant för så pass många människor att åtminstone en liten fraktion av alla människor du träffar till slut ska in till din butik.
Då tror jag antingen det är bättre då med mer nischade varumärkspositioneringar, att du, jag tycker Strongman exempelet är jättebra, det går att hitta i andra kategorier också.
Eller att man egentligen jobbar på att bygga ut kundstocken här och nu.
För det är här blandan när du ska komma in, brand versus performance.
Men man kan ju hålla ett tajt varumärke i termer av hur hemsidan ser ut, i termer av att du har snygga paket som du skickar ut till, att produkterna håller en hög kvalitet, en snygg design, och alla de grejerna är en del av upplevelsen av hur ditt varumärke fungerar.
Om det gör att du är mer benägen att komma tillbaka, men att du framförallt riktar dina reklaminsatser på att se till att hitta människor som är in the market för din produkt, så tror jag det är ett effektivare sätt att bygga ut ditt varumärke, för att ibland glöms det bort.
Man tror att varumärke bara är färg och form och logotyper, men en enormt viktig del av varumärket är ju volym av människor som bryr sig.
Om ingen bryr sig och du har jättesnygg font, det är helt useless.
Men om du har lite mindre snägg font och jättemånga bryr sig, då har du i alla fall ett varumärke att prata om, som du sen möjligen senare kan optimera för något annat utfall.
Säg att man vill bygga ett varumärke för att kunna öka sin pricing power, eller sin pris.
Finns det några...
Ett tag pushade ju folk att de var hållbara, eller funkar det fortfarande, nej.
Det har funkat.
Finns det någonting som...
Märker du på några varumärken att de här är duktiga på att bygga känslan av att här vill vi betala pengar, vad gör de som gör?
Totem är väl ett lysande exempel på ett varumärke som inte överhuvudtaget gett upp att växa snabbt.
De har ändå lyckats bygga ett lyxvarumärke får man säga.
I alla fall i svensk kontext är Totem ett lyxvarumärke.
Jag vet att om man läser modepressen, så anses det vara inom en for the luxury segment, men jag upplever att det är i ett ganska högt priset segment åtminstone i Sverige.
De har gjort det med en estetik och ett designspråk som tilltalar super snygga butiker och kommit ut i världen på ett sätt som är nästan svårt att förklara hur snabbt det har gått och hur stort de har byggt det där.
Så de har verkligen lyckats att hitta, alltså Bayredo är väl ett annat gott exempel som har lyckats väldigt väl.
Men vad är det de har gjort bra då?
Förutom att det är snyggt?
Nej men så här, Bayredo var ju lika, har ju typ, jag ska inte säga att de allra har förändrats men alltså så länge jag kan minnas Bayredo så har Bayredo varit lika snyggt.
Men under en väldigt lång tid så hände det inte så mycket med försäljningen.
De höll ju på, jag vet inte exakt hur länge men typ 10-15 år och var fortfarande under 100 miljoner i omsättning.
Sedan kom det in professionella ägare och vid något skede så exploderade det för att man lyckades få till distributioner, man lyckades börja kapitalisera någonstans på att ha hållit ihop det där varumärket väldigt tajt över lång tid.
Det kanske också var bara lite typ timing, att skandinavisk design helt plötsligt fick ett moment i världen och det gjorde att de kunde explodera ut internationellt.
Så det kanske inte heller bara var saker som de till fulla kontrollerade.
Så det är liksom, i deras fall då man lyckats, jag tror att det farliga med det är att varumärken i Sverige som omsätter 22 miljoner, tittar på Bayredo och säger att vi ska göra en Bayredo-resa.
Och sen så är lösningen på hur man gör det, det är att brandguidelines blir så tajt kontrollerade att det knappt går att göra någonting över huvud taget istället.
Och så blir man paralyserad för att man tror att att hålla allting supertajt är att bygga ett starkt varumärke.
Men då glömmer man ofta bort aspekterna för att det ska vara ett starkt varumärke så måste många människor bry sig.
Och det måste man...
Är det fortfarande ett problem?
Det tycker jag kändes mer som ett problem när folk på den tiden professionellt producerat innehåll fortfarande rankades som någonting väldigt bra, men det känns som att vi haft några år när alla har fattat att du ska typ filma dig själv i en weird vinkel och så blir alla glada.
Är det fortfarande så att folk är...
Upplever du från byråsidan att folk är känsliga med vad de lägger upp?
Troligt, absolut.
Jag träffade ett varumärke häromdagen som gör en...
som är en fashion-orienterat.
Jag gjorde en audit på deras konto och sen så sa vi att det går väldigt dåligt just nu, men för bara några månader sedan så gick det ganska bra på Meta.
Ni har stängt av alla era partnership ads och då hade de däremellan visat att de släppt en ny brandidentity och så sa de i den nya brandidentity så alla de här partnership ads de hade löpande som alltså är då personer, privatpersoner eller kreatörer på olika sätt som hade använt deras produkter och sen hade de lagt pengar bakom de annonserna och så sa de att de här kreatörerna de inte längre är on brand med vår nya brandidentity.
De sålde ju ändå era produkter, nu har ni stängt av allt det som fungerar på Meta och så har ni bara kvar det som är deras senaste fotografering som är stillbilder från en studio som ingen vill se.
De sa att vi kände att brandet höll på att försvinna iväg.
Och så sa de att nu håller brandet på att försvinna iväg för att ni inte säljer till någon istället.
De var okej med den förflyttningen och förstår inte då hur enormt negativ inverkan det skulle ha på deras varumärker för att bara använda det ordet igen.
Om man ska på riktigt jobba med varumärket, säger man såhär, nu ska jag sätta mig ner och tänka på detta.
Vad fan ska man göra då?
Jag tror att det finns typ tre varumärkespositioner som är vinnande inom DTC.
Det ena är det aspirationella varumärket.
Vi har pratat om Chimmy, CDLP, Totem.
De är inte alltid vinnande alla bolagen, men Totem har hittat en position där de är supervinnande.
Det går inom den vertikalen att göra det.
Sen har du det utbildande varumärket som säljer produkter som kräver ett ganska mycket utbildningselement.
Vi har jobbat med Skinon som har hudvård som förvaras i kylen.
Det kräver, det är inte bara att du ska sälja hudvården, utan det kräver också att du förklarar varför den ska stå i kylen.
Det är en barriär till att köpa, men när det väl får människor att köpa så kanske man i stället ser att de är väldigt benägen att stanna kvar för att de har köpt in i att det finns ett värde i att man har produkterna i kylen.
Det finns andra sådana brands också som är väldigt beroende av utbildning.
Då är det aspirationella momentet i de varumärkena att tända er att gå ner lite grann.
Fast oftast när man pratar om varumärksbyggande även på de varumärkena så handlar det ofta om att människor säger font och färg och så där.
Men det är inte egentligen alltid det som är det viktigaste.
Och sen det tredje typen av DTC-varumärk som tenderar att fungera, det är när man kan hitta någon sån här us versus them-position där typ Astrid Wild gör kläder för kvinnor.
De har en väldigt så här uttalad grej.
De kommer att alldeles göra en produkt för killar.
Det är väldigt kvinnoorienterat varumärket.
Det handlar väldigt mycket om att det ska vara för kvinnor i alla former.
De anordnar community-resor med bara kvinnor.
Det är liksom hela tiden det som står i fokus.
Och identifierar du det då in i den där gruppen där du tycker att det är väldigt alltså så här, att ditt kön på något sätt är väldigt definierande för hur du vill vända dig ut mot världen, då är det perfekt att tappa in i den varumärkesvärlden och vara med på den varumärksresan.
Det här är väl typ de tre största tydliga varumärkespositionerna där man kan se att varumärket har fått ta en stor del och bli en väldigt stor del av ett företags resa.
Men sen måste man ju oavsett var man är, ha produkt som fungerar.
Produkt är i slutändan oftast en väldigt stor del av din slutgiltiga framgång.
Men om jag kommer till dig då så säger jag såhär, vi borde täpa in i känslor någonstans.
Jakob, vad ska jag göra med gymkompaniet?
Vilken väg ska jag ta framåt?
Kan du såhär, nu sätter jag er på potkanten, men finns det någon riktning?
Vad skulle vi välja för?
Ni kommer aldrig bygga ett aspirationellt varumärke.
Det kommer aldrig vara att man kommer till gymkompaniet och så känner man att om jag bara köper produkter härifrån så förändras hela mitt liv.
Eller utseendemässigt ska jag säga så.
Möjligen att det förändras.
Ja, jag bryr.
Det är lugnt.
Ni hade möjligen kunnat hitta någon sån här asfjordsystempositionering.
Ganska många varumärken befinner sig i mer än en av de här bucketsarna parallellt.
Om man typ är i två fast det är ens med mer styrande.
Ni skulle kunna ha luta i det ganska mycket utbildningsmomentet, hur ska du träna?
Det är klart att om du hade drivit en podd som istället för den här podden som jag tror faktiskt skapar relativt lite värde för gymkompaniet.
Om du i stället hade drivit en podd som bara handlade om träning, du intervjuade Sveriges största träningsprofiler, det kunde vara allting från gym till endurance, och det hela tiden var så att människor kom in och lyssnade på din podd som också alltid var människor som köpte gymutrustning.
Så tror jag den podden hade haft större kommersiell impact för er att ta fram.
Du kanske inte tyckte att det var lika kul att driva den, men det hade probably haft större kommersiell impact och du hade kunnat ha haft nästan reklam i din egen podd för att du vet att alla som lyssnar är intresserade av våra produkter.
Så den utbildningsaspekten hade man då kunnat ha tagit ut i en podd, tagit ut i en YouTube-serie där du hade åkt runt och träffat träningsprofiler i Sverige.
Det hade ändå gett något så här top of funnel lager, kännedom om site, det hade gjort att fler människor kom till era site istället för att söka på produkt i Google, probably.
Så det hade väl varit kanske en enklast det.
Jag tror att det är lättare än us versus them att försöka skapa någon såhär vi som tränar mot dem som inte gör det, även om det finns var och när som försöks att få det.
Vi får fundera, det är bara jag som tycker det låter tråkigt.
Jag är så trött på att prata träning, jag har gjort det i så många år, det får bara vara klart nu.
Vi skiter i det, sen måste inte jag göra det, men jag har svårt att engagera mig.
Men är det inte så svårt att se att det skulle kunna skapa värden?
Absolut inte, den här podden var ju en träningssport från början.
Jag har intervjuat folk i träningsvärlden, det var bara att efter tio avsnitt kände jag bara, nej jag orkar inte med det.
Slut på frågor och sådant.
Jag orkar inte med det, det får vi bara nu.
Okej men skitsamma, vi hoppar vidare lite grann.
Om man inte ska bygga upp ett bolag på ett år och sen sälja det år två, vilket några människor säkert hoppas och önskat på.
Om vi ska bygga någon sorts långsiktighet i ett bolag och faktiskt skapa ett bolag som funkar över tid.
Finns det någon, alltså folk säger ju den här, antingen bygger man snabbt eller så bygger man stabilt.
Det är något sånt folk pratar om.
Finns det någon sanning i det?
Och ifall det finns någon sanning i det, vad är det folk gör dåligt när de bygger havsigt?
Det finns väl absolut någon sanning i det där, att saker som byggs upp väldigt snabbt kanske har en större risk att rasera ganska snabbt på andra sidan.
Jag är inte säker på att det egentligen har att göra så mycket med varumärken, men det är typ så här att hittar du väldigt stark product market fit av någon anledning.
Antingen är det på någon samhällstrend som din produkter rider, samhällstrender kommer och går och det riskerar att den där samhällstrenden tonas av.
Säg nu till exempel att nu är longevity och health en enormt stark trend i samhället.
Så det är lätt att investera i ett nytt bolag och tänka att det här kommer aldrig att förändras, att longevity och health kommer att vara ett fokus för all framtid.
Men så kanske det visar sig att inom tre till fem år då kanske det visar sig att man behöver inte träna så mycket längre för vi kan käka något tabletter som gör att man blir smal, i alla fall man kanske inte blir stark men man blir smal men då tar du direkt bort en jättegrupp i samhället som tidigare hade ett stort träningsbov.
Så vi ser ju redan lite grann med typ Osempic att det gör framför allt att amerikaner kanske har lite mindre behov för kardioträning nu för att de gjorde det bara för att se till att det inte blir, det runda inte allihop, men poängen kvarstår att samhällsdynamiken kan förändras med att varumärket klappar ihop.
Men alltså om du har byggt ett klädvarumärke som har växt 20 procent år över år i 30 år och du har på något sätt hittat dels en lojal grupp av människor, det är nya människor som hittar ett varumärke varje år.
Uppenbarligen så har du tappat in någon form av primal grupp i samhället som gillar ditt klädvarumärke och som tycker att det här är ganska nice.
Och sannolikheten för att det bara fullständigt försvinner på en eftermiddag är nog i regel lägre.
Sen finns det exempel på klädvarumärken som har tappat mark, men då sker det ofta över lite längre tid.
Det finns en gammal affärstes om att det kan ske lite symmetriskt.
Har du byggt det på tre år, kan det ras ihop på tre år.
Har du byggt det på 20 år, kan det ras ihop.
Men då tar det kanske 20 år förr och snarare ras ihop på andra sidan.
Så det är väl sant i någon utsträckning.
Och internt i bolagen, för du har väl ändå sett en del bolag som har vuxit snabbt.
Vad är de dåliga på internt?
Men det mesta skulle jag nog säga att de flesta snabbväxande bolagen är dåliga på internt.
Det blir också en schemär av att när vi...
Fan, det är så mycket bra ord.
Det är Svenska Akademins ordliste, jag ska fråga om någon kan sponsra oss.
När vi är på D-Congress eller på något annat event, så tenderar det ju att de bolagen som har växt snabbast vinner ofta priser.
Och för några år sen på D-Congress vann Skin City till exempel, som inte finns kvar ännu idag.
Jag har ingen insider information om Skin City, jag kan ingenting om det här bolaget och bolaget finns inte kvar, så det går ju hellre att inte prata med någon som är där nu.
Men oavsett då, så liksom när bolag växer snabbt, så tenderar de ofta att vara ganska grundarberoende, för att det är någon individ som står och domderar i mitten i viss utsträckning.
De tenderar också ofta, för att själva tillväxten sker ofta på grund av product market fit.
Det finns massa människor som hjälper sig att köpa deras produkter.
Det gör att man inte behöver vara operationellt skicklig, de är ofta inte jättebra på marketing.
De geniv förklaras ofta för sin marketing, de är ofta i regel inte så bra på marketing.
Man behöver inte vara såhär konservativ medan man anställer personal, för att försäljningen sker automatiskt.
Så man behöver inte investera så himla mycket i marketing.
Det gör att du får massor med lönsamhet i botten.
Den kan du välja då att återinvestera i liksom, vi pratade tidigare i för något avsnitt sen om lifestyle-investeringar i termer av att köpa granola till kontoret, men en annan lifestyle-investering det är att bara ha en extra person som är ansvarig bara för kontorstrivsel.
När min mamma jobbade på SAS när jag var åtta, då hade de kontorutfrösande vik där de fortfarande har kontor, och då fanns det en typ gågata på kontoret.
Där fanns det en människa som var ansvarig för att den här gågatan skulle vara mysig och bjuda in artister och annat till den här gågatan.
Det är typiskt sådant exempel som låter helt absurdt i efterhand, men då tjänade SAS mycket pengar som helst, och då var det helt logiskt att ha den där personen anställd där.
Samma grej händer på enasbolag som växer för snabbt.
Typ Nynepine opererar fortfarande med ett pyttelite team, de är säkert svin duktiga på det de gör, så man ska inte dra alla över en kant.
Men det finns absolut exempelbolag som har växt för snabbt, bra programworkfit och inte alls är egentligen jättebra på allting.
Och så måste de lära sig allt det där istället när bolaget omsätter 100, 200, 300 miljoner.
Det som man oftast kommer in och lär upp i större ursäkt när en bolag omsätter kanske 15, 20, 30 miljoner.
Och så tänker man att de där som bara kommer till 25, de är mycket sämre på det här än de som kommer till 150, men det behöver inte alltid ro på skicklighet.
Det är väl på något sätt ett lyxproblem om man börjar växa väldigt fort, eller det blir lite märkligt.
Men om man vill stärka upp, man vill bli långsiktig, man vill slippa de här svackorna som en del snabbväxande bolag får, vad är det viktigt att ha på plats i ett bolag som verkligen fungerar väl?
Jag tror att risken är att du har någon grundargrupp, det är ofta en, två, tre, fyra personer, det är ofta två personer.
Om den grundargruppen vet med sig själva att de inte är erfarna inom e-handel, då är det viktigt att man inte geniförklarar sig själv för att det går snabbt.
Någonstans måste man bara inse att det är nog rätt mycket som jag inte fattar eller kan, för jag är helt ny i den här branschen.
Det kan inte vara så att alla andra e-handelsoperatörer är idioter.
Så har jag helt plötsligt kommit från flanken och bara är mycket smartare än alla andra.
Mer sannolikt är det inte så.
Och ifall du då inte är erfaren när ditt bolag ändå växer snabbt, då är det viktigt att omge dig med några personer som har sett lite mera absendans genom åren.
Så om du nu ska göra anställningar, anställ personer som faktiskt har sett grejer.
Det absolut vanligaste att säga är att man anställer nedåt.
Man anställer personer som är relativt juniora.
Många juniora personer bygger stora team som har väldigt låg erfarenhet ihop.
Och om du istället anställer någon då du känner att den här personen skulle kunna komma in som CEO på det här företaget, de är tio år före mig i karriären, de har varit med om en crash på ett annat företag, de var med om det här och de har lyckats med någonting.
Och få in den erfarenheten i en sådan organisation så att den personen kan börja hjälpa till och se till att vi inte ska göra samma misstag som gjordes som de har varit med om tidigare i karriären.
Det tror jag är en viktig del för bolagen som växer snabbt och enkelt.
Jag kan bara tänka mig att om jag har ett bolag som omsätter 40 miljoner och så tänker jag att nu ska jag ta in en duktig CFO eller COO, någon C-tjänst liksom.
Om de kommer från ett stort bolag, dels känns det inte som att de är kompatibla med ett litet bolag, dels känns det som att de har en lönernivå som gör att det blir lite bizarrt för mig i ett litet företag att helt plötsligt betala fyra gånger meter den här personen än alla andra i arbetstillkan.
Dels tycker jag att det känns lite svårt att hitta motivationströsken.
De kommer kanske inte att motiveras av det som jag motiveras av.
Upplever du inte att det blir en liksom...
Man kan ju motivera människor med personaloptioner om man anställer seniorpersonal in i någonting snabbväxande.
Det ska väl vara en del av en sådan komponent.
Jag tycker även att man då kan trycktesta lite på lönesidan i att du kan ha lite större uppsida mot exekveringsrisk, men du behöver ha lite lägre lön.
En del människor är inte bekväma att ta en sån förflykting i livet och är man inte det då kanske man inte passar riktigt på en startup.
Man behöver en person som har en vilja att gå från kanske 80 000 i lön på en arbetsplats och komma in på din arbetsplats och få 55 men har en uppsida på att den ska kunna tjäna ganska mycket pengar om tre år ifall saker och ting fortsätter gå i den riktningen som det redan gör.
Om man vill investera i en månadslönssänkning ner på 25 000 kronor när man är 8-10 år in i karriären och mot det förhoppningsvis kan få ut några miljoner om några år, då blir man oftast rätt motiverad ändå.
Då är man nästan lite konstigt lagd om man inte hittar att det brinner lite i knutarna.
Ja, alltså i teorin funkar det, men ser du sådana exempel ofta?
Jo, men det skulle jag absolut säga.
Alltså anställer man till C-suite i ett bolag med 3,4,5,6 anställda, alltså ett väldigt litet bolag någonstans, men som växer snabbt, då måste man nästan ge ifrån sig personaloptioner för att kunna få rätt personer.
Gör du inte det och bara motiverar med lön, då är det otroligt svårt att hitta en win-win plus att det är svårt att hitta människor som får det startup-hustlet i kroppen.
Sen så tror jag tillbaka till din första poäng, att om du anställer någon från ett jättestort företag, så tror jag att det ofta är väldigt svårt.
H&M till exempel har producerat massor med skickliga människor, jag känner människor som jobbar på H&M, men om en av våra kunder säger att vi är på väg att ta in en person, en person som kommer från H&M, så duktig kan massor, då är jag verkligen såhär, sätter ner ett extra varv och bara pratar igenom vad det här kommer att innebära.
För de är van att vara i en organisation med 10 tusentals människor, där det kommer mycket grejer serverat, där man har sommartid på sommaren och går hem en extra timme tidigt, där det liksom inte har varit kniv mot strupen typ hela deras karriär.
Framförallt människor som har varit där under hela livet, de har inte nödvändigtvis ens sett hur det faktiskt är att jobba på ett företag där det brinner lite mer i knutarna.
Och i många fall har jag sett när människor kommer från typet H&M eller från en annan organisation som ofta är ett väldigt framgångsrikt företag, men har en kultur som är svår att transferera över in i ett litet bolag, det är annorlunda att jobba på en startup.
Vi är en deppig liten värld, man får jobba hårt och alla måste slita.
Låga löner.
Ja fan, för jävligt.
Om vi går igenom trappstegsresan för bolag, jag tänker att vi behöver inte sätta exakta omsättningsmodeller, för det kan ju skilja ganska mycket, vad som är litet stort och även hur mycket personal man har.
Men om man är en e-handel som är i starten på sin bolagsresa, vad är det viktigaste att få på agendan?
Vad är det man behöver naila för att kunna ta nästa steg egentligen?
Product market fit är väl någonstans det viktigaste början, att se till att du har en produkt.
Det bör kännas ganska enkelt när du lanserar dina metanonser.
Jag förstår att det är väldigt otacksamt att säga det, för i regel utvecklar man produkten först, nu ligger den på ett lag och sen så ska man gå ut och sälja dem.
Men om det inte är lätt att spendera tusen kronor om dagen och få det att bli lönsamt, då är det otroligt svårt att tro att det ska kännas enkelt när du ska spendera 10 000 kronor om dagen lite senare i den resan.
Och 10 000 kronor om dagen var fortfarande ett ganska litet bolag.
Så det är väldigt viktigt att ta in prispunkten av marknaden.
Var i en marknad som ändå har någon form av behovsbild.
Se till att, och det här är väl innan du ens lanserar, se till att du säljer en produkt som du verkligen tror är behövd och har en någorlunda attraktiv prispunkt.
Och som du på något sätt kan säga är unik gentemot konkurrenter.
Sen kan man alltid fundera på hur unik behöver den vara.
Du behöver inte alltid vara lika unik.
Är den billigare i pris så behöver den inte vara så unik överhuvudtaget.
Men liksom, du behöver ju ha något claim to fame när du går ut och annonserar.
Om din produkt är precis som alla andra produkter då är det inte så spännande om du inte lyckas bygga upp en väldigt stark brandpull men det är ytterst få som lyckas med det.
CDLP är ett väldigt gott exempel på det där jag tror att de flesta som har varit i kontakt med CDLPs varumärke tycker att de gör någonting otroligt häftigt.
Jag jobbar med CDLP.
Jag tycker att CDLP är toppen.
De har ett superduktigt kreativt team inhouse.
Men CDLP är fortfarande ett relativt litet bolag idag och de har ändå hållit på i många år och tagit in stora investeringar genom åren.
Man ska ha respekt för hur sjukt svårt det är att bygga ett varumärke som skapar tillräckligt mycket dragningskraft för att kunna bygga ett enormt stort företag.
Jag tror att det ibland underskattas.
Människor tror att deras varumärke kommer att dra åt sig så många intressenter.
Sen visar det sig att det är ganska tufft.
Man har i alla fall fått någon sorts product market fit.
Man säljer, man kan till och med vara lönsam utan att lämna över marknadsföring till någon annan.
Man är på den nivån att man till och med gör fel och ändå går det ganska rätt.
Sen börjar man jobba själv i bolaget, man tar ut sin lön.
Man börjar anställa sin första person, där är vi någonstans.
Vad är det man inte får fucka upp i det skedet?
Inte ta in personerna för tidigt.
När du tar ut själv lön, då kanske du kan ta ut en lön när du börjar närma dig 3-4 miljoner eller nåt sånt.
Eller när du i alla fall har 3-4 miljoner i forward looking sales över de kommande 12 månaderna så är väl det inte helt orimligt.
Ganska svårt när man är mindre än så.
Om man sen så när du ska anställa en till då kanske du snarare börjar närma dig 10 miljoner eller åtminstone har 10 miljoner över de kommande 12 månaderna.
Och då är det väl viktigt att fundera på vad den nästa personen ska göra som kompletterar dig.
Så det är en fälla att bara anställa för att göra de grejerna du tycker är tråkigt.
Det är väl väldigt vanligt att känna i början att vi ska anställa en person som ska sköta kundtjänst.
Det är väl en av de absolut vanligaste rollerna som grundare säger att de ska anställa för tidigt.
Jag tror egentligen att det är en mycket bättre tankegång att över en längre period äta upp en del av kundtjänst själv, försöka få bra AI-processer numera på plats för att ta upp så mycket av kundtjänst som möjligt.
Sedan när nästa person kommer in så anställer man inte dem för kundtjänst men man säger att vi är ett litet företag, som del av ditt jobb här så kommer du behöva lägga fyra timmar i veckan på kundtjänst.
Det behöver vi alla göra och sedan så gör man det mer som en nästan teambuilding-grej att vi behöver tillsammans ta hand om våra kunder även om det inte är det någon av oss tycker är roligt att sitta med just kundtjänsten.
Sedan när man är kanske lite större, när man är en bit över 20 eller närmast 30, då kanske det är en FTE som ska ha kundtjänsten själv.
Men jag tror också att det finns någonting med att som tidigt DTC-bolag att vara ganska nära sina kunder och när du sitter i kundtjänst då hör du om problemen som händer med dina produkter, du hör om leveransproblemen och att du hör om de grejerna dagligen det gör också att du blir mer proaktiv själv.
Och är såhär, okej men om många upplever att det är svårt att förstå det här innan de ska göra sitt köp, då får vi stilla att adressera det på PDP-en i vårt welcome flow, i våra annonser och så blir du helt plötsligt lite bättre på att konvertera människor utan att de skriver in.
Samma grej med att såhär, ja men den här sömmen spricker eller det här fungerar inte eller vad det nu är, liksom om du får höra de här klagomålen så blir det väldigt verkligt.
Och då försöker du lösa de problemen och då blir du ett bättre företag.
Jag tror verkligen det.
Jag tycker att folk anställer alldeles för snabbt i kundtjänst.
Jag tror, jag är inte säker på omsättningen exakt, men jag tror att jag var ensam upp till 25 miljoner på kontoret.
Och då blev det exakt så där.
Man blev pinsamt att ta vissa frågor.
För att, den här tog jag ju igår också, varför har jag inte skrivit upp det här på hemsidan?
Eller vi kan inte ha löst det här problemet än.
Så då löser man ju väldigt mycket uppenbara grejer, bara för att man vill inte ta den frågan igen.
Man orkar liksom inte, eller så känns det akord.
Och bara, fan vad dålig jag var på att leverera en tjänst.
Eller alltså, det är mycket lättare att förklara bort om det är en annan kollega som tar hand om det.
Det är absolut okej.
Och sen när man börjar komma upp någonstans, när man börjar känna sig som en vd, du vet.
Ja men nu är jag ansvarig för fyra, fem personer här.
Oj nu gör vi en budget för nästa år.
Du vet saker börjar kännas på riktigt.
Vad är det som är farligt där?
Då är man väl någonstans runt så här, en liten bit över 30 kanske, 30-40 miljoner.
Om man har kanske då att säga till ett team att man är fem, om man rättar ett bolag på 40 miljoner, då känns ju fortfarande bolaget väldigt, väldigt litet ska jag säga.
Ni är fem fortfarande på kontoret, det är ju er lilla kontorsäng, det är väl vanligare att man är det vid 40 miljoner.
Men det är nästan konstigt när man ska gå ut och käka lunch med hela företaget, då ser man att man inte kan sitta vid ett stort grundbord för att det är för stort förrän.
Så i regel är upplevelsen att man är liten, jag tror att innan man startar e-handel över lag så tror jag att man tror att ens bolag ska tjäna större när man är vid tio och vid 20 än vad det gör.
Sen visar det sig någonstans att, oj vad litet företaget är fortfarande.
Jag trodde livet skulle vara klart när vi omsatte tio.
Nej exakt, så att det liksom...
Jag kunde inte ta in hur bolag som omsatte över tio miljoner inte kunde ha allt serverat bara, för du har så mycket pengar.
Exakt, så att när man sen rör sig mot 30-40 liksom, då börjar man väl komma till en punkt där man behöver sätta lite tajtare processer på plats.
Det behöver bli liksom, det finns en så här...
Jag pratade med Juniper-teamet i veckan och så berättade de att förut använde de Asana väldigt mycket och Asana är ett projektledningsverktyg där man lägger ut rör.
Men allt eftersom har de använt det mindre och mindre, för teamet växer inte, teamet står typ stilla.
Juniper växer men teamet växer inte.
Men alla vet mycket mer vad de ska göra idag än vad de visste för två år sedan.
Och då fanns det väldigt stort behov för att ladda upp alla to-do'erna hela tiden så att man kunde checka av dem en efter en.
Men to-do'er är ju relativt återkommande, åtminstone på ett säsongsjul, att vi går igenom kampanjer och fotograferingar och allt vad det är.
Och allt eftersom så har det här blivit mindre viktigt.
Så jag tror att det är bra att fundera på vad är processer som måste finnas på papper, för det är lätt att tro att man snarare måste migrera mot att man måste använda Asana bara för att bli mer kompenserad.
Om teamet är beständigt, man har duktiga personer som lär sig, man ska inte bygga tekniska processer bara för saken skull, även om de måste sitta i människors arbete, så måste de inte dokumenteras.
För att jag tror överlag att dokumentation, att sitta och bygga powerpoints i små organisationer görs alldeles för mycket.
Man kommer ofta, någon har erfarenhet från ett större företag från början, på stora företag byggs det powerpoints, och sen så bygger man gärna powerpoints internt när man ska skicka saker till varandra.
Det är bara så sjukt tidskrävande.
Lite lättare nu med LLM än någon sådär som kan spotta ur sig powerpoints ganska snabbt.
Så det kanske kommer bli mindre av en tidstjuv framåt, men överlag, historiskt, så känns det som att det där är en stor tidstjuv.
Att fortsätta vara väldigt effektiv, anställa, sparsmakat i efterhand, de grejerna som är viktigast är vid 30-40-50.
Och hela tiden ha ögonen någonstans på att vi fortfarande är ganska små.
Hur tar vi oss till 100?
Vad är 100-vägen?
Är det att vi måste lansera i andra länder?
Till exempel, många bolag kan ju ta sig till 30-40-50 i Sverige, men någonstans på vägen om man ska börja fundera på resan till 500 så är det antagligen en del av pusslet att du måste ut i andra länder.
Och andra länder tenderar ju att fungera lite grann som din hemma marknad gjorde bara från år ett, snarare än från där du står idag.
Så att när ett 100 miljoner kronor bolag lanserar i Norge så ska man inte förvänta sig att det blir 12 miljoner i omsättning år ett, det kan mycket väl bli 1 miljoner i omsättning.
År två kanske blir 2,5 miljoner så säger man, det här är ju ingen skillnad man bara åker med, vi växte just 150 procent i den här marknaden.
Det är jättemycket i den marknaden, det är bara det att den nominella siffran spelar ingen roll för moderskettet längre.
Men är man villig att fortsätta investera i marknaden när man växer 100 procent ett par tre gånger till då är det plötsligt en ganska stor marknad.
Att sätta igång de där snäbollarna och fundera på vad är den lättaste marknaden att sätta igång efter det här är väl också någonting man gör där i krokarna.
Jag tror också väldigt mycket på det.
Det är väldigt löjligt att sitta sista december och säga att nästa år ska vi växa med 15 procent nu, så nu ska vi ta fem initiativ som ska driva 15 procent nästa år.
De borde ha tagit för tre år sedan de initiativen.
Nu kommer vi att ta initiativ som växer ett procent nästa år och sedan om tre år växer de 15 procent.
Så att man ligger lite i förväg där.
När man börjar komma upp där i lite massor, om man är över 100 och man ska upp och bli ett ett riktigt bolag på riktigt, eller vad ska jag säga, den fasen jag är i nu, vad är det jag kommer att fucka upp i det här nästa året?
För det första som ska vara med sig är att de flesta bolagen, om man tänker på hela Sveriges DTC-landskap, tar sig inte till 500 miljoner.
Du kan nästan räkna på ena handens fingrar hur många svenska DTC-bolag som har tagit sig till 500 miljoner.
Om du dessutom från den resan tar bort dem som växte kopiöst mycket när Facebook fortfarande var gratis 2015-2016, då är det otroligt få kvar.
Det är några stycken och Revolutionary har gjort det jättefint, RideStore har växt senare år, etc.
Men man ska ha respekt för arbetsuppgiften.
Lite tillbaka till det här att med tanke på hur sjukt svårt det verkar ha varit för många som kom före mig, så får man också ha en acceptans för att det probably kommer vara svårt för en själv också.
Ett problem kan vara manskapsproblemet.
Bara för att man var rätt person för att leda bolaget från 0 till 100 miljoner, så är det inte nödvändigtvis att man är rätt person för att leda bolaget från 100 miljoner till 1 miljard.
Jag är inte ens säker på helt ärligt talat att det alltid är en person som är bäst beskaffad och tar det från 100 miljoner till 1 miljard för att 100 miljoner är fortfarande ett relativt litet bolag.
1 miljard börjar det ändå bli ett riktigt bolag, lite kropp i företaget.
För att få en känsla så att ett hemtex har plus minus cirka 1 miljard i omsättning, de kanske har lite mer vid det här laget, men de har kanske en organisation på 50-60 personer och då börjar det ändå bli lite företag av det och omsätter man 1 miljard, en väldigt tung del som i hemtex fall är i Sverige, då har man mer eller mindre fullständig varumärketskännedom.
Var det som man handlar på hemtex eller inte så vet typ alla svenskar vad hemtex är.
Ganska få DTC-bolag kommer att ta den vägen.
Det kommer nog att handla om internationalisering för att få till en miljarders försäljning.
Då ska man ut i världen och där kommer det komplexiteter som möjligen avhälps lite grann av olika tekniska lösningar med AI som gör att det blir enklare.
Jag tror att sätta sig ner med ägare eller mentorer eller vad det nu kan teckas vara som man har tillgång till när man omsätter som du gör runt 100 miljoner och fundera igenom vad ambitionen med bolaget är.
Du äger ju typ bolaget själv.
Du kanske inte vill att det ska omsätta en miljard eller kanske i alla fall inte har det som en...
Du kanske vill att det ska omsätta en miljard men det kanske inte egentligen spelar så stor roll om det tar 40 år att komma dit.
Du kanske bara vill rulla på på jobbet och då är det helt fine så länge det är kul att gå till jobbet.
Eller är ambitionen att det ska säljas vid 2, 3, 4, 500 miljoner.
När vill man ska säljas?
Där tror jag svaret på när man vill att bolaget ska säljas dels är det en effekt av när man har någon som vill köpa men det är också en effekt av när det spelar en meningsfull roll för en själv som ägare så att säga.
Om någon skulle komma till dig och ge dig 50 miljoner kronor i handen så kanske man kan säga att det är alldeles för lite, gymkompaniiet är för stort, whatever else liksom.
Men man kan också säga att 50 miljoner är en fruktansvärt mycket pengar.
Det kanske faktiskt är att en så meningsfull inverkan på ditt liv att det kanske hade varit värt att ta det.
Nu kanske du inte alls vill ha några pengar men poängen är någonstans att fundera på när på den här företagsresan din själva av ägarandelen gör att det faktiskt varit värdefullt för dig att sälja det här bolaget.
Det tror jag också är någonting att fundera på där.
Det kan vara olika trigger points för olika ägare eller för olika grundare.
Därför att någon hade varit otroligt värdefullt att få loss 5 miljoner och för någon annan så säger de att jag bryr mig inte om 5 miljoner för att jag ska vara villig att sälja och behöver göra 50.
Så kan man fundera på hur man hanterar de komplexiteterna på resan från 100 miljoner uppåt.
För när du kommer upp mot 2, 3, 4 100 miljoner då finns det köpare i regel av bolag ska man säga.
Skulle du säga att det finns någon standardiserad grej du kan se när bolag börjar stagnera oavsett om det är på 10 miljoner eller 50 miljoner eller 150 miljoner, är det ofta det här de inte har gjort eller som de gör som gör att de stagnerar?
Det är en foregone conclusion typ men det är ju alltid en fråga om att nykunnsanskaffningen börjar takta av och märks kanske inte alltid direkt att den gör det.
Sen så går det tre, fyra, fem, sex månader när fortfarande återkommande kund handlar en hel del.
Så att din försäljning kanske fortfarande växer, växer lite mer försiktigt men narrativet på kontoret är ofta att vi är inne i en liten stagnering men det kommer att ta fart igen.
Sen så upptäcker man efter sex månader, nej men det som händer är inte att det tar fart igen, utan det som händer är att det faktiskt viker neråt ännu mera.
För att de återkommande kunderna helt plötsligt inte har en tillräckligt mycket nya kunder som kommer in underifrån.
Då pekar pk2-pilar neråt och då är det liksom, då är du helt plötsligt inne i ett arbete där det kanske tar ett år att liksom komma tillbaka till då du var sex månader tidigare.
För att det är så sjukt svårt att få till vänningen på nykundsanskaffningen.
Du var antagligen sämre kreativ eller du når inte ut till tillräckligt mycket nya människor.
Du har kommit in i den här cykeln där du liksom inte klarar av att nå ut till nya människor.
Det kanske innebär att du måste börja marknadsföra i Norge, vilket du inte alls har gjort innan och det visar sig vara mycket svårare.
Det här är ingen som litar på ditt varumärke och så vidare.
Det är typ alltid det vanligaste.
Det spelar alldeles ingen roll.
För vissa bolag sker det här vid 20 miljoner, för vissa bolag sker det vid 50 miljoner, för vissa är det vid 150 miljoner.
Man kan alltid kämpa mot det här, man kan se till att fortsätta lansera flera produkter, kunna se till att varje kund kan handla mera, man kan skapa fler produkter mot ny publik och så vidare.
Men om du inte håller stenkoll på det här och gör det allt eftersom och ser till att du aldrig riktigt tappar momentumet, då är det väldigt lätt att du stagnerar när du väl har kommit dit.
Och att inte stagnera betyder det mer produkter, mer kategorier, mer länder, mer kreativa, eller är det mer att...
Performancebyråer överlag säger ju alltid att det handlar om kreativ volym, men kreativ är ju bara ett sätt att nå ut till fler människor.
Om du lanserar yogakläder som du berättade om var en dålig idé, då är det klart att det var ju med en idé om att probably nå ut till fler och nya kunder.
Men då gäller det att man kan göra det på ett kredibel sätt, där de flera nya kunder ändå känner att det var någlunda enkelt.
Och ganska ofta lanserar man ju produkter för att man tänker att den här produkten ska ändå min kund köpa, då kan de kunna köpa den av mig.
Då är det ju per definition inte nödentiskt nått ut till nya kunder.
Men som Juniper gjorde nu under våren och lanserade en sänkläderskollektion som är ungefär 30 procent billigare än våra existerande sänkläder, då kan man låta människor luta sig in i Junipers varumärkesvärld.
Den här nya sänkläderskollektionen är produktmässigt meningsfullt skild från vår existerande sänkläder.
Det är en perkelväv istället för en satängväv.
Ah, men då sa du.
Den är krispigare istället för att vara slät.
Så människor kan komma till Junipers butik online eller fysiskt och rationalisera sitt köp av den billigare produkten.
Inte genom att säga att jag vill köpa det billigare, utan genom att säga att jag föredrar att sänkläderna är lite krispiga så jag skulle ha den här produkten.
Det är ett sätt att ge en kund en out.
Alltså, när du sitter på en restaurang och så kommer någon fram och säger att de vill ha den här eller den här, så det är ingen som vill svara, jag vill ha den billigaste vinflaskan.
Men om man kan ge kunden en out och säga att du har den här som är lite mer fruktdriven och så har du den här som är mer träig av sig, och så ser man att den är mer trä, kostar 1400 spänn flaskan och den fruktdriven kostar 700 spänn flaskan, då kan man ju välja den här, jag gillar den lite mer fruktdriven, då blir det toppen att ta den där.
Och låta kunden rationalisera för sig själv eller för personen som är i sällskap med att säga men jag föredrar features av den produkt som är billigare därför köper jag det.
Det tror jag är bra, jag tror att det här gör att Uniper kan tappa in i en ny målgrupp, Unipers adresserbar marknad växer.
För tidigare så var det bara människor med en viss ekonomi och då kanske några människor i skiktet som tycker att det är lite väl dyrt, har ändå gått och suktat lite av att köpa de här produkterna, men nu kan köpa en produkt som är lite billigare så att det blir enklare.
Jag tror på det sättet att Unip bygger ut sina adresserbar marknad, så att det blir nya kunder man kan åka till och därav kan växa varumärket.
Om vi vänder bara på frågan som är den sista frågan på det här segmentet, kan du se någonting på företag som har väldigt stadig tillväxt?
Är det någonting de gör, och då snackar jag inte över tre år, utan jag snackar över tio år.
Är det någonting de gör väldigt bra, tycker du?
Antingen så ska du vara i en produktkategori där när du köper in lika många nya kunder varje år, så är det så tacksam custom lifetime value-beteende att fler och fler människor varje år kommer tillbaka.
Har du en produkt där du teoretiskt sett har infinite retention så att alla fortsätter att köpa vidare, då behöver du aldrig öka din marknadsföringsbudget.
Du lägger tusen kronor varje år, du får in några nya kunder och sen så stannar de kvar för alltid.
Allt eftersom så blir de återkommande kunderna fler och de nya kunderna färre som andel av totalen.
Du tjänar mer pengar, din kost går ner och allting är great.
Det är ett sätt att växa ett e-handelsbolag.
Ett annat sätt är att du ska ta in fler och fler nya kunder och så finns det förstås alla mellanpunkter på något sätt däremellan.
Ska du ta in fler och fler nya kunder då måste man hela tiden ha med sig att du behöver på något sätt driva förbättring på din sida av ekvationen.
Antingen genom nya produkter eller ny annonser eller sajt.
Ibland träffar man bolag och så säger de att vi gjorde precis samma sak förra året, varför fungerar det sämre nu?
Och sen är det ju för att ni gjorde precis samma sak förra året.
Chansen för att ni skulle kunna öka marknadsspenden med 20% i en konkurrensutsatt marknad på en auktionsbaserad plattform och att ingen annan det här året skulle ha förbättrat det de gör är väl typ noll.
Så det är klart att om ni gör samma sak som ni gjorde förra året, ni försöker spendera mer pengar, då kommer det gå lite sämre i år än vad ni gjorde förra året.
Ni måste ju hela tiden förbättra er mer än vad resten av marknaden gör.
Så om ni har förbättrat er 8%, då kanske ni är flat i performance.
Och om ni förbättrar er 16%, då kanske ni faktiskt outperformar marknaden som helhet och därmed kan växa på nykundsiden i år också.
Jag gillar det.
Tack Jacob, jag tror att vi stänger ner dagens avsnitt där.
Toppen, stort tack.
Jag har ju en gräsmatta men de har inga röralflårenkläder.
Jag har valt andra approachen på det varumärket.
De kör gymkompaniiet istället.
De har gymkompaniiet.
Det är klart de har.
Allting som går att dra på företaget, vi ska dra oss av på företaget.
Det är merch.